[Music]  there are rumors  rumors i tell you that the next pope  could be an american cardinal sean  o'malley from boston that's right he  could become  could become  could become the next pope of course if  that happened he'd be the first american  pope in history the first yeah  think about it  an american pope would mean big changes  at vatican city first would see a much  cooler pope hat you know that right  yeah we'd say  we'd see a slightly different popemobile  i think uh  could add a flat screen tv to the  sistine chapel i think it would be a  good idea  he'd make dave matthews a saint ladies  and gentlemen  and finally an american pope would  rename saint peter's basilica verizon's  the christ zone  [Applause]  what are we doing what are we doing what  are we really doing  is this really the best use of our time  i'm blaming them for my foolishness  what's wrong with all of you